the biggest problem with relationships these days is
everybody thinks
“you're supposed to meet my needs”
here's why that's never going to work
People usually have a relationship that goes one of three ways
the “if you don't meet my needs, I'm going to leave”
which is pretty immature
Or the Equality route which is great,
the “you do your part, I'll do mine”
but there's no real passion there okay
and then there's the third relationship that will always work
which is the “I'll do whatever it takes to meet your needs”
these relationships always work
Their equally passionate about meeting each other's needs
because it fuels them every day when they wake up
when they first open their eyes
they want to meet your needs because it drives them
that is the key essential component to a long lasting relationship